- I'm Jordan, I'm a sophomore at Harvard.
I'm first-generation college student.
My dad works two, three jobs.
My mom's still working.
My grandparents, coming from Puerto Rico,
and that kind of thing, and
not having any education.
So from two generations
ago, my grandparents,
not even going to middle
school, to me being at Harvard,
I think that is not only symbolic
of the hard work that it took to get here,
but it just shows that you work hard,
you can really do anything.
(uplifting, exciting music)
With my dad always telling me, you know,
education is what's gonna
take you to the next level.
No matter where you go to school,
no matter if you're in high school,
no matter if you're at the
best university in the world,
Khan Academy can be used anywhere.
Just having that 24 hour,
free online resource
that I have used in the past
and am going to continue using,
to eventually help me reach my goals
of one day going to medical school.
And one day, eventually becoming a doctor.
Being the first doctor in my family
is going to be something
that's remarkable,
and it's gonna mean a lot to my family.